c'est habitante de saint bris le vineux
sont en colère ils veulent sauver leur
parc et ses arbres centenaires
le site doit bientôt laisser place à un
futur groupe scolaire
mais pour eux l'emplacement choisi pose
problème
il ya un véritable problème de sécurité
qui a mal été abordée ou pas été abordée
en tout cas pas suffisamment notre goût
vous avez une route là qui est très
passante
un déversement de l'autoroute on a très
peur que les tronçonneuses arrive et
qu'il soit détruit
très rapidement une pétition en ligne
pour sauver le parcours est recueilli
plus de 800 signatures
mais pour le maire la commune n'a plus
le choix le bâtiment actuel qui
accueille l'école n'est plus aux normes
il en va de la sécurité des enfants si
vous êtes dans l'escalier de secours de
l'école ce sont les issues de secours du
bâtiment qui ne sont plus du tout
adaptée qui ne sont pas qui permettent
pas de protéger les enfants
il a fallu une dérogation pour que
l'école puisse rester ouverte
mais si rien n'est fait elle devra
fermer le maire dit ne pas avoir les
finances pour engager des travaux selon
elle
construire de nouveaux bâtiments
seraient moins coûteux et permettrait de
garder une école dans la commune des
groupes scolaires il est vital pour le
village et peut-être même pour les
villages alentours puisque on risquerait
si on perd notre école on parle de
commerce à ces galeries dans le futur
groupe scolaire ne devrait pas voir le
jour avant septembre 2021 ses opposants
eux veulent saisir la justice et
envisage de constituer une liste en vue
des prochaines élections municipales